je vous le dis je vous dis la vérité
arié il vient de voix pour un film d'une
ou deux au cinéma demain alors alors
elle ni une ni deux ni une ni deux
normands seymour ans et mon père noël
manche me rappelle mon père à chaque
fois que je recevais le bulletin sur la
tête de ma mère sur la vie de ma mère
que c'est vrai d'histoire on l'a tous
entendu mon père imap et mère est basque
avait été bonne à bangadi ton père votre
par les éditions indie certains je vais
rentrer ce soir ni une ni deux joues et
esquinté jamais made in you need the
town un cadeau à chaque fois il y avait
ni une ni deux d'ailleurs 6v l'esquinter
se gausse je vais l'esquinter vote
vous reconnaissez lara sera franchement
quand vous êtes chez vous vous avez reçu
le bulletin sur la tête de ma mère je la
connaissais tu passeras mais moi je
l'avais les bras et entend les clés de
ton rock qui rendent son daron qui
rentrent à la maison et frère et tu sais
que toi tu es dans ta chambre
mon père il prend sa vitesse et ses
palmes à te mettre la tannée tout de
suite ils te laissent un peu qui fait
dans ta chambre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après j'ai compris moi non pas de vente
à darron il peut pas faire genre le mec
est oublié et donc même s'ils voulaient
pas tant que les iata darron tu lui mets
un coup comme un mille en train de
manger frères matata ball kamoun sais
pas où je peux les merguez fictifs comme
ça et est atteint mais après j'espère
que tu vas lescott et t'inquiète pas je
mange ni compris les bosses et quant à
des frères et soeurs mon père était
comme ça il en train de manger bas de
tableau ou bien parce que non je connais
plein blizzard
si le tram ou bien il sait pas immense
jeu ils mangent du doigt la section de
merguez voilà ils mangent comme ça à mon
frère eyad d'onfray rotary fond patin et
toi et toi mais il y aura le soir où tu
reçois le bulletin c'est le seul soir où
t'as pas faim tabac ils t'appellent
chaque fois serrée la venger non c'est
bon j'ai pas peur je vais travailler je
travaille un peu bavé falette
[Applaudissements]
on a tous connu ça non non non non on
voit bien travaillé les codes on
apprenait même à l école j'aime bien
travailler à l'école
pourtant on a même des stances mounir
m'attendait je rentrais c'est toujours
un très beau bulletin une fois j'étais
deuxième c'était un peu agacé away sinon
je travaillais très bien je travaille
régulièrement chaque course mais c'est
moi qui vous ai demandé minutes vous ai
pas résultat moi c'était les cassettes
pour adultes et j'avais les vieux dhs à
l'époque pour ceux qui ont connu la
cassette admettez milan avant de sortir
et j'avais la clé de la soeur de mon
père j'ai passé d'habitants porno lui
non on a tous dans la même émission
peut-être peut-être que vous êtes dans
une autre émission au soir vous êtes
excusé moi raymond we offer livre amis
quel est votre problème et sa femme
susan boyle ndour et mon salut raymond
je rappelle le thème de la soirée mais
attendez ségo ferons sans risque à
minuit c'est la folie et bien sûr on est
sur voltage ségosphère d'un acteur à
dispo ici a dit dès qu'il ya du canada